why do men
let's say a large fraction of men love
boobs
well uh i i think that uh
you're one of the uh most cited
evolutionary psychologists
and this is what you signed up for this
is these kinds of questions questions
like this yeah yeah well so again this
is something i haven't studied directly
but um
uh
scientifically yes yes uh but um but
yeah there's been some work on that and
and it's uh another cultural quirk
perhaps no i don't think it's a cultural
quirk because i think it's the uh
the shape
that matters a lot because
shape is going to be a cue to fertility
uh and so one of the things that humans
are attracted to in the opposite sex is
sexually demorphic features and breasts
are a sexually dimorphic feature and
dymorphic mean
difference between difference in
morphology between males and females got
it
um
diminishing to morphic morphology
uh so um
and women don't develop uh
breasts until um
puberty or post-puberty
uh and and so uh as a sexually demorphic
characteristic we tend to be attracted
that same is true by the way with the
waist-to-hip ratio that we mentioned
earlier
prior to puberty males and females have
very similar ways to ratios but at
puberty
there's a differential
hip development and fat deposition that
creates a sexual dimorphism uh with
respect to waist up ratio and so again
that's
men are attracted to this wasted ratio
that no man consciously says that they
find this woman more attractive than
that woman they don't think ah she has a
waist up ratio of 0.7 oh that's exactly
what i do but
most men most men yes